[Music]
just got the update from seton the
french kid uh there'll be a lot more
he's joining us at the top of the final
hour but if anyone has any questions
about the mercedes sprinter van
on off
tough weather here's a little bit
oh by the way that's southern texas
they're in
they're not in uh north dakota that's
the colors that's what this is supposed
to look like right storyteller overland
covered in this looks slush this looks
like you can tell a story
yeah i talked to him yesterday last
night they were they said
we're gonna try to drive straight
through to phoenix yeah and then we'll
sleep in the sprinter van if we have to
there that's southern that's south of
san antonio there's and it's a ice storm
here's they at one point were in fort
hancock texas which is on the border of
mexico you could hit a golf ball you
could hit a golf ball to it it's where
andy dufresne and his buddy red crossed
after you remember they escaped in
shawshank redemption
so that's how far south they are they're
they're at the border for a point last
night they were at the border of mexico
well they couldn't get into el paso
because the there was
they closed a bridge or something
we'll see
a lot of updates a lot of driving they i
said man i'm really sorry about this and
seton goes
what are you sorry about this is awesome
greatest week of your life he goes
it you know it's going to be tough
giving up the van because
this
this is what made it fun because you had
you're able to drive that
so we'll have an update later today
his seating with us is signal counter
with us on the road
seton where are you right now
uh somewhere
uh
outside of
that's not good
that's not good where you're somewhere
well that's kind of what uh it feels
like a lot of new mexico it's kind of
somewhere
oh you're not even in arizona yet
no no not even close
okay recap what happened yesterday and
last night with you and the french kid
so yesterday uh we we left houston at
about eight o'clock in the morning
and we were hoping to drive there was a
little band of the storm that we were
going to drive right through that we
were like all right we'll see how bad
this is hopefully it's not too bad on
the other side and so we made it through
the storm pretty well i mean the weather
got crappy you know and it was it was
really windy there was um kind of like
freezing rain a little bit of snow stuff
like that and then we got through like
the worst part of the storm but then it
was the area that we were driving into
was really really icy and it turns out
and now that i remember this from our
dallas super bowl days texas doesn't
handle ice very well
and so uh you know we got we got stuck
in this one bit of traffic it was just a
dead stop for
uh i don't know 45 minutes or something
like that and we found a way to take a
u-turn that road was obviously closed
because of the ice so we found a way to
make a u-turn
and then just sort of like bit and
pieced our way through the state um and
so we drove for i think it was about 15
or 16 hours
which
houston
to phoenix should be about 16 hours and
instead we did houston to el paso in 16
hours were you almost down in mexico
oh yeah we were we were close enough
that we were playing the game like do
you think those lights are mexico right
there yeah
yeah yeah yeah but yeah paulie said that
you were in a place called fort hancock
or you went by i drove through there and
that was the shawshank redemption i mean
that's that's where andy dufresne
was at uh and then morgan freeman joined
him
yeah i mean it's possible by the end of
this me and the french kids could be uh
sanding a boat on the beach somewhere
you're gonna quit you're gonna quit the
show and you and the french kid are
gonna run off
okay that's it we're running off with
the van we're gonna go get a boat and
we're gonna build it together damn it
okay what is today's goal
today's goal uh
we're absolutely getting to phoenix
today there's no doubt about that so um
well knock on wood um no we're today
we're gonna end up in phoenix today and
then we're gonna see uh what tomorrow
holds uh when we get there okay if you
can't make it to vegas
then you can just go to los angeles
whatever whatever you're comfortable
doing i'd like for you to do a drive-by
in vegas but if you can't then uh just
go to los angeles
well i just want to make sure that you
guys are going to make it through the
week actually because just it sounds
like
you guys are getting on each other's
nerves more than me and brendan are
well okay you got friday fritzy friday
pre-super bowl fritzy oh good grief
yeah uh we got we got friday burgers
you know some i it sounds a little more
enticing being in a in a van for 15
hours with a french kid that's hurtful
well there has been there have been a
couple of times yesterday that we were
getting through some pretty dicey spots
where we're like wow this is like we i
can tell you this this week so far has
been the best advertisement for this
vehicle that you could possibly imagine
because it has handled some unbelievable
uh weather and terrain but there have
been a few times that we've been in some
situations where you're like man can you
imagine if todd was driving right now
all right all right stay in touch
all right yeah i'll check in with you
guys a little bit later on all right all
right that's seton o'connor and the
french kid on the road somewhere when
somebody goes where are you and you go
somewhere
that's not a good start
but in somewhere in new mexico right